now that we've finished building the UI
for our app it's time to think about how
it should operate when it's not in the
foreground one of the most powerful
features of Android is the ability for
any app to run in the background but
with great power comes great
responsibility so you need to be very
conscious of how it's consuming
resources in this lesson you'll learn
more about how the android framework
manages background apps and you'll be
introduced to the service class to help
make that happen
you'll also learn techniques for
efficient data transfers using sync
adapters in Google Cloud messaging and
be introduced to the notification
framework to send messages to your users
when your app isn't in the foreground